money counterfeiting is almost dissolved
as money itself when banknotes were
first issued in Europe in the 17th
century they were crude and easily
duplicated some historians believe that
counterfeits in circulation outnumbered
real banknotes to make paper money
harder to forge there's been a stream of
innovations from elaborate engraving
watermarks to security thread but these
technologies couldn't prevent a $900,000
swindle back in 1966 in Australia which
is how we got plastic money to replace
the pound and the shillings and the pen
in 1966 Australia switched from pounds
to decimal currency the country's
Reserve Bank issued a new range of
banknotes with modern safety features
including watermarks woven metal thread
and raised areas thanks to being printed
on intaglio presses soon though
fake $10 notes that looked authentic
began to appear in the following years
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of Australian fake notes all with
watermark and metal threads passed into
circulation undermining confidence in
Australia's new money
it wasn't the work of a sophisticated
criminal mastermind but instead a
shopkeeper an artist photographer and a
tailor financed by career criminal
Robert Kidd the gang watercolour
printing press a camera lens and some
ordinary paper the photographer took
pictures of a genuine note and a
watermark drawn by the artist the tailor
took a week to printing training and ran
it with the shopkeeper in a garret
the counterfeiters was soon caught but
the authorities were alarmed by how easy
they were able to copy the money so in
1968 the then governor of the Australian
Central Bank HC Coombs challenged a team
of experts to create a more secure
banknote
a representative from camera company
Kodak made the point that if the new
banknotes could be photographed then
they could also be printed and forged it
inspired David Solomon a polymer chemist
he came up with a novel idea of a
plastic note after being given a
business card printed on plastic by a
Japanese professor
within a few years Solomon's team
developed a unique polymer substrate
which contains several film layers the
molten polymer is forced out of a
circular die in the form of a bubble the
bubble is drawn up a tall vertical tower
the size of this bubble and hence the
film thickness is controlled by the air
pressure within the bubble using polymer
meant other security features could also
be included see-through panels contain
optically variable devices holographic
style images that are hardcopy we'll
take a photo of printed on plastic it
incorporates for the first time anywhere
this optically variable device which
takes on a different appearance
depending on the angle at which you view
it in 1988 the new technologies were
first used in ten dollar commemorative
notes the technology has now been
exported to 25 other countries as well
as their security features polymer
banknotes are also cleaner and they last
two and a half times longer than paper
notes which offsets the increase in cost
at the end of its lifecycle the plastic
note can be recycled to make other
products today plastic money is used in
about 30 countries and accounts for 3%
of the world's money in Australia
plastic notes have helped keep
counterfeiting low for decades
especially when compared with other
major currencies like the Euro the rate
has increased in recent years though as
the criminals have caught up so the best
solution might just be to go cashless
entirely that would also help avoid the
embarrassing spelling mistake Australia
printed on 46 million of its bills this
year
you
you